all right so you know your first year
when you're walking around with that
around your neck don't make that mistake
in this video i'm going to break down my
top seven back to school essentials as
well as my top five biggest waste of
money items always recommended to
architectural students in their first
years of university and college if you
stick around to the end of the video i'm
going to share with you my absolute
favorite item from this entire haul that
i still use today as a qualified
practicing architect that cost less than
forty dollars but let me be clear a back
to school architecture hall is
expensive i hope your piggy bank is full
because this isn't going to be cheap now
yes you can absolutely 100 cheap out but
don't forget architecture is a very long
degree and if you're going back to
school for architecture you don't want
to be buying things twice so let's start
off this video with my top five do not
buys it doesn't matter who tells you
what i guarantee you that all of these
items will collect dust very very
quickly the number one item on this list
is a portfolio bag i guarantee you that
any first year architecture student
walking across campus is carrying a
portfolio bag and at the same time i
guarantee you'll never use it yes they
might try and tempt you to use it in the
first couple of weeks just so you get
some value out of purchasing this couple
hundred dollar bag but in reality it's
gonna sit in the back of your cupboard
for five straight years while you go
through your entire degree so save your
money don't buy the portfolio bag next
on the list is a storage tube and yes
technically speaking every architect
depicted in every movie ever has some
sort of storage tube and is carrying
around hundreds of rolls of paper under
their arms but again in the modern day
and the modern age you hardly ever carry
around any papers yes i still do carry
around papers and yes you still will
carry around papers however one roll of
paper under your arm is absolutely fine
a little bit of water on it is never
actually going to happen and the reality
of you requiring a storage tube is so
low it is not worth the money at all so
on this list is extremely controversial
and i guarantee you everybody is going
to advise against it however in my
personal experience i went out and
bought every single architecture book
available on the recommended list that
set me back close to a thousand dollars
in my first year and what i found out is
that when you rock up to every single
class with all those books in your
backpack ready to go eager to learn not
one single time are you gonna have to
pull out 95 of those books my honest
opinion is go out to your first week of
classes cop the grunt that comes with it
by not having all of the recommended
books with you and then make sure you
purchase the ones that are 100 essential
you can find 90 of the information in a
second handbook or online for 100 free
so i don't think you need to spend all
of the money on all of the recommended
books second last on this list is copic
markers now unless you are already an
existing artist who knows what they're
doing
freehand sketching designing and
performing very well in 2d animations or
even 3d representations on a piece of
paper copic markers are going to be the
biggest waste of money yes they're
phenomenal as an architectural tool yes
you can create some amazing 2d
watercolor designs landscape
architecture elevations but if you don't
know how to freehand draw you're
absolutely wasting your money because
nowadays they don't teach you how to
draw in architecture school they teach
you how to design using digital software
and technology though unfortunately the
day of architects knowing how to draw
and being trained to draw is long gone
number five on the do not buy list and
the last one on this list is a personal
favorite of mine it is the t-square
there is absolutely no reason any
architecture student should still go
around carrying a t-square now let's
move on to the architecture essential
must buy haul list for all
back-to-school architecture students the
number one on this list is coffee now
you're going to need so much coffee to
get through architecture school because
if you don't pull an all-nighter have
you really gone to architecture school
whilst you're at a supermarket grabbing
your coffee you may as well move on to
number two and grab some baking paper
now traditionally speaking architects
use yellow tracing paper and this is
absurdly expensive it can be anywhere
from fifty dollars all the way up to a
couple hundred dollars for some tracing
paper what i learned very quickly as a
poor university student is go to the
local supermarket
get some non-greased baking paper for
one or two dollars and it is the perfect
tracing paper number three on this list
like i mentioned before is a digital
item it is something that you're going
to need to produce great quality work
and because nobody draws freehand
anymore that means you're going to be
using a computer 24 7 to do your work
you are going to need a good laptop at
architecture school regardless if you're
planning to work at home or at
university i do often recommend a pc
rather than a mac for all architecture
students going in because pcs cater to
all of the architectural software which
i talked about in my last video compared
to what mac is actually compatible with
so pc is by far the easiest choice if
you don't know what software you're
going to be using to pair with pc you're
going to need the perfect mouse carpal
tunnel is dead serious in architecture
and you're going to need an ergonomic
mouse i have two of my personal favorite
recommendations one is the mx logitech
master iii mouse which is the be all
end-all of all mice and it is something
that anybody will recommend to you for
anything however the second mouse that
i've personally found to be actually
extremely comfortable while sitting and
doing an absurd amount of work on the
computer is the kensington wireless
mouse for life now i have linked all of
these things down in the description
below if you want to check them out next
on the list is my absolute favorite
black book in the world this little
black book is a typical moleskine it is
a hardcover moleskine because as an
architecture student this is the one
thing that you need to carry around
everywhere without this moleskine book i
probably would have failed my degree i
probably would have forgotten every
single thing somebody taught me but i
used to go through about three to five
of these every single semester because
it was my bible now i recommend the
moleskine with the grid lines over any
of the other mole skins because it is
incredibly versatile you can do
everything from architectural drawing
through to some basic note taking on the
grids and the paper feels incredible
paired with a great fine liner now
because we do live in 2022 you can very
easily scrap the moleskin and buy
yourself a brand new ipad paired with an
apple pencil this thing will do
everything that a moleskin wheel except
that has a battery life personally i
used to go in with an ipad and then i'll
go back to my desktop at home to take
all my notes whilst i was at university
and actually do my work at home so i
never really had a great laptop that i
always took into university and then did
all of my work there because i didn't
see the value in it but if you're unlike
me and you do actually want to go to
university stay at the college campus
for as long as you possibly can and do
all of your studying in the dorm rooms
in the library or wherever you see fit
you're probably going to need a good set
of headphones and you're probably going
to want them to be noise cancelling as
well so a set of beats by dre will do
the job perfectly well as will some
apple airpods pro
but you will need a set of good
headphones to be able to drown out all
of the other students and basically stay
in your flow state for as long as
possible to do some of the best work for
prolonged periods of time especially at
a huge time crunch anyway that's all for
me today guys thank you so much for
watching my name is david thomas and if
you enjoyed the content and want to see
more of it there is a playlist to the
side of me with great architectural
information available for free and if
you really love the content i'd
appreciate it if you smash that
subscribe button but like always i'll
see you next monday